let me show you my favorite plant books
root
nurture grow what i love about this book
is that it focuses on propagation only
so we will find step-by-step
instructions for different propagation
methods
as well as a very useful table that
provides
which method is best for each plant the
well-gardened mind
this is a beautiful book and i can tell
you it's helping me discover how the
relationship with my plants
can help me improve the relationship
with myself
living with plants my favorite part of
this book
is that it gives us ideas on how to use
player plans
and really step-by-step instructions on
planned diy
projects gardening under lights i can
tell you this was a life
saver last winter because it has all
information a plant beginner needs about
grow light
and how not to kill your houseplant with
caregivers for more than 100 plants and
pictures of all of them just in case you
don't know the name of yours